oh oh praktisch praktisch hallo Leute
hier ist wieder eure Meinung und
willkommen zu einem neuen
Adventskalender Auspacken Video und
heute gibt es den möbel Höffner
Adventskalender und bevor ich 100 mal
möbel Höffner sage dieses Video ist
nicht gesponsert und jetzt alle dieses
Videos nicht
im Kalender
voll in der von Möbelhaus ich weiß gar
nicht was mich erwartet ich denke mal
die werden so in weihnachtliche Deko
reingehen letztes Jahr hatte ich den
Deko Adventskalender von tertiano oder
Tiziano und da waren leider nur weiße
Keramikfiguren und so drin ja und
ansonsten ist ein weißer dicker
Adventskalender ne da wäre es vielleicht
praktisch gewesen wenn ich mich damit
ein bisschen mehr auseinandergesetzt
hätte vielleicht erwartet uns heute
genau das gleiche wir werden sehen er
ist auf jeden Fall wieder von der
Kategorie so groß dass wir beide nicht
ganz aus Bild passen deswegen versuche
ich mich hier ein bisschen zur Seite zu
quetschen aber ja was hast du gekostet
okay hier müssen wir wahrscheinlich
wieder ordentlich zusammenrechnen ach
wahrscheinlich wird es aber auch schwer
sein ich weiß nicht ob ich heute
zusammenrechnen kann je nachdem was da
drin sein wird der Adventskalender
kostet 99 € und hat einen Warenwert von
über
250 Euro ja ja ja ja jetzt geht's rund
rund
das ist doch mal ein Angebot Leute ich
kann euch ja schon mal dass ich mich zur
Zeit mit Adventskalendern selber machen
befasse und eine Sache die mir jetzt
schon mal auffällt ist dass das schon
ganz schön krass ist dass man eigentlich
bei so vielen Kalendern so wenig Zeit
und dafür so viele Produkte bekommt und
so einen großen Warenwert weil das
Verpacken dass die seinen das also das
das ist ja alles das kostet alles Geld
und dass sie das dann immer so dumping
mäßig auch raushauen können die Leute
Stunden zählen ich glaube aber der große
Unterschied ist wenn man eigene Produkte
einfach den Kalender reinpackt oder
Produkte zusammenpackt wie jetzt bei
Daniela Katzenberger oder Barbara
Schöneberger oder you name mit allen
anderen Öffner wo wohnen wenig kostet
das mal sehen und ich sehe schon das
Tierchen Nummer eins und wir öffnen das
jetzt okay alles klar Höffner was was
wird uns erwarten okay das finde ich
gerade so lustig ich habe von denen
nämlich deren Adventskalender auch
bestellt der ist aber noch nicht
angekommen freue mich so auf diesen
super Streusel Adventskalender ich bin
halt voll der Typ für solche bunten
Sträuße müssen wir zusammenrechnen ich
bin mir nicht so sicher 99 Dings 250
müssen wir Zusammenbruch nein ich bin so
entschlossen ich weiß es nicht ich will
es nicht glauben aber hierfür bezahlt
man schon so seine 4,50 € superstreusel
sind super Preise Nummer
zwei in Nummer 2 befindet sich eine
Mystery BAG oh nee Mystery ist es nicht
eine Silikon Backform cute also so in
diesem Beutel kommt ja also wir würden
100 Sachen einfallen die ich damit
machen könnte irgendwie Schokolade oder
dann kann man keine Ahnung Pudding sonst
was da rein machen und so schön für die
Weihnachtszeit dann ist geil oder ein
kleiner Kuchen ich finde die mega Rolle
Spielchen und sehr weihnachtlich ne da
freue ich mich ja immer persönlich
drüber die meisten Kalender die wir hier
aufmachen damit ich wirklich ein
weihnachtlichen Inhalt manchmal hat was
ein bisschen Zimtgeschmack oder so aber
so ein richtiger Weihnachtskalender ist
schon cool Backform in viel ach das wird
nicht geben das ist ich will dafür Leute
das mit dem Preise raussuchen wird
glaube ich bei diesem Kalender schwierig
weil ich denke viele Produkte sind auch
einfach für den Kalender gemacht und ja
Fragezeichen
4 ist der der Duft also
steht hier keine Marke wir werden diese
Produkte einfach auch nicht finden
dieses Mal gibt es keinen Preise
raussuchen ich weiß ihr liebt es aber
ich habe keine Ahnung wie ich das
Produkt finden soll da ist kein Hirsch
also ich nee ich finde es aber nicht
raus
das ist eine Kerze okay okay bei dem
großen hätten sie vielleicht auch zwölf
auf einer Seite 12 auf der anderen weil
dann muss man das ja immer so rum reden
vier
oh oh ja an dem Türchen haben wir
Weihnachtskarten oder sind das
Weihnachtskarten
schönes Design erinnert mich ganz
bisschen an diese Ikea Phase wo sie
diese ja diese schwedischen Symbole
immer so hatten plus drei Umschläge
meine Damen und Herren weiter geht's mit
Türchen Nummer fünf
also wirklich ne was ist das denn bitte
wieder für ein schönes Design ich heule
made in Portugal die packe ich in die
verlosungsbox die packe ich jetzt nicht
aus eine honigmandelseife wirklich tun
das ist sehr gut jetzt kommt natürlich
in sechs ich bin bis jetzt happy mit der
Auswahl oh Türchen 6 ist klein
ja hör mal 10 Euro die richtige nicht
mein kannst richtig zu möbel Höffner
gehen finde ich gut also 100 € hätte ich
auch gut gefunden aber das ist mega
keine Schokolade den packe ich in die
Verlosung ich will ja nicht jetzt schon
sagen ne aber irgendwie gefällt der mir
richtig gut der Kalender Nummer 7
kann ja irgendwie so gefühlt alles drin
sein
papierornament yes
jawoll ich dachte wie macht sich das
gleich fest mit Magnet natürlich
er ist wunderschön aber sieht meine
Damen und Herren bei einem wirklichen
weihnachtsadventskalender da lacht mein
Herz ich habe gemerkt nämlich beim
Pamela reif Adventskalender Fitness
Spiegel und so das interessiert mich
dann doch nicht so sehr wie
das hier das ist wir sind wieder also
ich finde das ist wie jeden Tag
irgendwie so ein Geschenk kriegen let's
go Leute Nummer acht
gefertigt in Handarbeit ey ich weiß ich
weiß das ist so unnötig eigentlich ne
aber dass man so seine Kerzen ausmacht
also falls ihr nicht wisst was es ist ne
das ist hier
ein Kerzen ausmacher und dann ist die
Kerze aus wenn ihr diesen Winter werden
wir wahrscheinlich viele Kerzen benutzen
vor allem weil ich mir immer so einen
kaufen und dann dachte ich so ja gut es
ist nicht nötig sowas zu haben so
auszupusten es geht voll klar jetzt hat
das Schicksal entschieden dass ich sowas
haben soll ich glaube der Kalender kann
jetzt nur noch verkacken indem jetzt in
Küche Nummer 9 Sticker drin sind
na klar Servietten Ring Set also sind
sie wahrscheinlich nicht das teuerste
Türchen oh das ist toll ich liebe es
aber ich finde vier Stück sind blöd also
das hätten sechs sein müssen ich cancel
euch noch nicht möbel Höffner aber sechs
werden schon toll die schenke ich meiner
Schwiegermama weil die hat auch schon so
Filz Dinger und dann hat sie Dings
Andrea das ist für dich das ist ein
toller Kalender das sage ich dir wie es
ist ne
ja möbel Höffner ist gut ey bitte
schauen Sie selbst die Nummer zehn okay
was ist das irgendwie erinnert mich der
an den Westwing ja wohl ohne
Witz
doppelbinder klassischer also riechen
tut die nicht gut was sagt ihr ist schon
eine tolle Schürze ist schon cool in der
Weihnachtsbäckerei Leute ich finde das
Design auch schön etwas Weihnachtliches
aber man kann es nach Weihnachten auch
noch weiter gut tragen und es ist nicht
nur so ja Weihnachten in deine Fresse
rein und für alle Kinder ich meine
natürlich nicht in die Fresse rein
sondern ähm Weihnachten ganz doll viel
ja ich glaube ihr werdet mich kein
schlechtes Wort über diesen Kalender
sagen hören Nummer 11 ja voll lot
doppeltürchen das bedeutet oh Gott ja
ich liebe diesen Kalender
oh Gott schick einfach schick einfach
genau der Blödsinn den ich haben möchte
von Peil und putzler sogar zwei Stück
für mich ist es das perfekte Level an
kitscht toll ich vermute ja ja natürlich
natürlich
schön kitschig
ach qualitätsmäßig tip top
Timo hier Max noch einen Kaffee nach dem
Weihnachtsessen
ich liebe oh mein Gott
ich habe mal so ein weihnachtlichen Deko
Kalender von Westwing ausgepackt und der
war auch gut aber ich finde möbel
Höffner hat das bessere Level an Kitsch
also das ist das tollste mit Glaswaren
und Leuchten schreibt heil und putzler
Geschichte seit 1903 der Einfluss großer
Gestalter wie Wilhelm Wagenfeld spiegelt
sich bis heute in der Formsprache
unserer Produkte und wir machen das
durch Nummer 12 Servietten oder wie ich
gerne sage Servietten diese Servietten
haben Dackel drauf und ich liebe Dackel
ich glaube in dem Universum stehen
gerade alle Sterne so richtig gut für
mich weil dieser Kalender ich liebe
dieses
guck mal dieser Dackel hat ein Geweih
und ein Geschenk die sind so toll
Nummer 13 ist hier sehr groß
eine braune Kiste wir lieben braune
Kisten da ist doch bestimmt schon wieder
irgendwas saugeile
es ist ein Teeglas und dann ist hier
auch noch aus Glas und dann macht man
hier den Tee rein macht zu und dann legt
man das so da rein und
was für eine Überraschung das gefällt
mir auch ich finde dieses Glas ist auch
toll geformt
Nummer 14
also was soll ich sagen ne toll mega
früchtete Mischung ja die sieht also
wirklich auch toll aus nee das ist ja
schön ne ähm ich weiß gar nicht von
welcher Marke das ist ähm wahrscheinlich
also ähm ja machen wir mal weiter mit
dem nächsten Produkt Nummer 15 na klar
Leute die passenden Küchen
Trockentücher für meine Schürze mit
Datteln drauf würde ich es noch besser
finden jetzt wo ich weiß dass man Dackel
rentierohren draufsetzen kann und die
super süß dadurch werden bin ich ein
bisschen beeinflusst aber auch schön
ja bitte Schoko Fondue die sahen ehrlich
also die sehen aus wie so kleine
Macarons die zehn sind das für ein
riesiges Türchen
guck mal guck guck guck guck guck da
kannst du dein Essen warm reinmachen und
was ach so kannst du dir mal spekulutons
für deine Suppe oder für dein Müsli
kannst du kalt und warm haben bisschen
random gerade wenn ich so an die ganzen
anderen Produkte denke die doch sehr
weihnachtlich sind dann so ein Essen
aber okay wir nehmens wir nehmen es
erstmal okay wir haben noch so viele
Türchen vor uns 18 oh okay ich ich war
gerade so verwirrt was und schauergel
aus einer Sektflasche das ist okay ich
finde immer also wenn es nicht von der
wirklichen Marke ist oder Firma die man
so etabiliert in Deutschland kennt dann
habe ich immer bei sowas so Nanu-Nana
Vibes müssen was ich meine so Spaß
Produkte wo die Qualität jetzt aber
nicht wirklich überzeugend ist aber ja
süß akzentrat wann Akzenta waren doch
auch die Akzenta waren auch die die
diesen EMP Wellness Adventskalender
gemacht haben diesen duschprodukten Bade
Gel und so wir sind also qualitativ okay
die machen so ihren Job aber es ist
jetzt nicht so glaube ich toll vegan
friendly okay gut also
ich gemacht
ein Flasche wir sind in den 20ern
angekommen und es gibt jetzt
die Magic geht gerade so ein bisschen
kaputt ein Tischtuch ja schön ich finde
aber leider muss man sagen ähm wenn man
zu zweit ist ich meine okay viele Leute
sind zu zweit aber ich meine viele
Familien haben mehr als nur zwei Plätze
und da ist das wie bei den Servietten
Ringen ja also nur zwei ne das ist so
schwierig da hätte ich vielleicht eher
darauf verzichtet aber wenn man zu zweit
ist dann ist es toll das ist aber auch
wie mit den weihnachtstassen die ich
vorhin ausgepackt habe man kann ja nicht
wissen wie viele Leute im Haushalt leben
und weiß nicht ob man dann direkt ganz
auf die Produkte verzichten sollte oder
halt einfach zwei also bei denen das
finde ich unnötig also da hätte man das
aber gut dass Timo und ich zu zweit sind
und 20
oh mein Gott litter Staub von cake stuff
wow boah wie viel vor allem ist es nicht
also sind solche Dinger nicht immer
sonst so klein dass man halt so ein
bisschen Gold wo drauf machen kann hier
ist gleich so ein riesen Paket macht
absolut Sinn ist sehr toll sein 20 oh
hier haben wir wieder Handarbeit
kleiner Christbaumschmuck ich muss
aufhören Christbaum zu sagen Tannenbaum
sind zwar Handarbeit also ja gut das ist
glaube ich nur der eine schon sehr
klassische so ein bisschen rustikal
sehen die aus vorletztes Türchen okay
der Kalender muss jetzt wieder ein
bisschen ich habe das Gefühl der hatte
jetzt so eine Low Phase also am Anfang
habe ich die Produkte mehr Flash
deswegen hoffe ich dass er vorletzte Tag
noch mal richtig reinhaut und uns war
das geiles skip so bitte bitte nicht
oder nein doch nicht
oh ja okay doch oh ja na klar also ich
persönlich muss sagen ich verschenke
immer sehr viele Flaschen
und das ist ein toller Beutel um eine
Flasche zu verschenken und es ist
wiederverwendbar das heißt wenn du die
nächste Person eine Flasche verschenken
möchtest dann sieht das wieder benutzen
das ist ein cooles Produkt das hat
wieder ein bisschen umgerissen jetzt
kommt the moment of truth wir haben den
24 wir fanden unseren Höffner
Adventskalender ganz ganz toll wir sehen
nicht ganz den wahren Wert von 240 €
doch wahrscheinlich schon ja also 99 €
haben wir wieder reinbekommen wir sind
wieder viele tolle Produkte gewesen aber
die 24 die wird uns jetzt zeigen warum
wir so viel Geld ausgegeben haben nee
Regen Schokoladenfondue also ich habe
noch keins die geben mir so einen
leichten billoide möchte ich eigentlich
nichts dran aufspießen es ist süß ich
mal gucken was das kostet aber irgendwie
ich bin bei technischen Geräten einfach
nicht so ein Fan von so
22,99 € kostet der
dafür ist es wahrscheinlich schon
gut dann so ein Teil zu holen aber ja da
kann man sich bestimmt tolles Foto
mitmachen dann haben wir hier sogar
schon Schokolade bekommen das heißt wir
können das gleich ausprobieren ich habe
nur bei solchen Gerät wenn man das
Gefühl ich esse mehr Plastik als
Schokolade das was ich meine ich bin
vielleicht so ein bisschen auch verwöhnt
so WMF verwöhnt und so weil bei mir muss
das irgendwie jetzt muss ich immer alles
so wertig anfühlen okay Leute kommen wir
zum Fazit ich muss sagen ich finde das
ist ein toller Kalender
die letzten
Produkt ganz vielen tollen Dingen die
man an Weihnachten super gebrauchen kann
und für weihnachtsfans für so Muttis wie
mich die dann auf solche Sachen stehen
ist das alles echt toll ganz besonders
dieser Tee hier nee es ist ein toller
Kalender schön weihnachtlich ein
bisschen mein Fazit schreibt gerne in
die Kommentare was ihr dazu denkt würdet
ihr den genauso feiern wie ich also auch
mal wieder so ein perfekter Kalender
auch den man seiner Mutti schenken
könnte wir machen hier viele Moody
Kalender auf aber ich bin auch eine
Mutti im Herzen deswegen freue ich mich
über so Tassen im weihnachtsdesign für
andere könnte das ein Ramsch Kalender
sein ne aber für mich sind wirklich sehr
süß wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal
wieder tschüss
[Musik]